Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Wir äh leben die Zukunft.
Netzpolitik Nummer einhundertunddrei und äh heute sind wir etwas, heute ist es richtig morgen Linus, oder?
Heute ist richtig, richtig echter Morgen.
Ja und wir sind äh wir sind total in der Zukunft und und und leben das hier gerade mal aktiv. Das ist jetzt hier bisher wirklich noch so die ähm,
wie soll man das sagen? Das ist so richtig Zukunft, so im Hotel sitzen und irgendwie durch dünnes drei G eine Sendung aufnehmen.
Und Zukunft wäre letzte Woche gewesen, da hätten wir siebentausend Kilometer Distanz gehabt. Jetzt sind's nur gerade mal hundert noch was.
Naja,
Na ja, lass mich doch angeben. Immerhin äh haben wir mal wieder Zeit gefunden, nach dem letztes Mal ähm wir von äh Andres hervorragender Einsatz äh zehren konnten.
Schaue direkt nicht richtig. Die ist einfach nicht richtig.
Was ist nicht richtig.
Unterperformt.
Hat er? Ja. Wieso?
Ja. Der andere hat mich groß angestiftet zu dieser Aktion im im Bundestag ans Mikrofon ein NSA-Aufkleber zu machen.
Und geht in meinen eigenen Podcast und erzählt halt nicht.
Stattdessen labert der lustlos die Stellungnahme runter, ja, von der in dem Auftritt im Prinzip gar nichts zu äh zu hören war. Also nee, das war nix. Das war nix.
Okay, dann müssen wir das mal kurz hier für die Chronik nachtragen.
Ja, ich habe.
Äh überall, du bist sozusagen ähm mit einem dicken Farbeimer zum Bundestag gelaufen und hast überall hingeschrieben äh Roman um E und Dormus.
Nein, nein, wir standen äh wir standen auf dem Hof der Republika, bevor ich dann äh los rüber musste zum Bundestag und dann äh holt der Andre irgendwie verteilte da wieder so diese NSA Monitor Device Aufkleber,
äh und äh gab mir dann einen und meinte, hier kannst du in den Bundestag hinkleben, trotz dich eh nicht.
Ja und dann bin ich halt in den Bundestag gegangen, hab mich da schön hingesetzt und hab den schön mittig genau am äh am Mikrofon positioniert,
Und äh dann,
In dem einen in dem Sitzungssaal, ja, also quasi an meinem Mikrofon. Und äh ja, dann äh bin ich wieder gegangen und dann bin ich zum anderen gegangen, habe gesagt, hier habe ich wohl getraut.
Ja und der das konnte er nämlich nicht ertragen, das konnte er nicht ertragen und deswegen hat er es nicht erzählt, deswegen hole ich das hiermit nach.
Hm, okay. Man sieht äh dich dringend ist äh.
Inhalt, der Inhalt, der Inhalt führt, ja? Ähm,
und und außerdem war der, äh, war das, äh, war das Gespräch, glaube ich, sehr anregend. Ich kann das nur empfehlen, sich das nochmal anzuschauen. Ich fand das ein, ein sehr interessantes Fachgespräch
und ähm der andere spannende Teil, der da den anderen, glaube ich, auch nicht erzählt hatte, ist, dass äh die CDU erstaunlicherweise sehr,
ähm begeistert war von meinen Ausführungen, namentlich der Herr Thomas Jazz Hombeck, der äh dann direkt äh meinte, ähm,
sollte öfter eingeladen werden und außerdem möchte er mich dann bald mal in seiner Arbeitsgruppe begrüßen,
zum vertiefenden Austausch zu Themen der IT-Sicherheit.
Und das fand ich natürlich auch sehr äh eine sehr interessante Wendung, weil damit hätte ich natürlich nicht gerechnet. Üblicherweise äh wenn irgendwo jemand von der CDU sitzt ähm ist der jetzt nicht so, dass er sagt, was der Neumann sagt, ist gut.
Ja. Vielleicht kannst du ja für die äh Hörerinnen, die jetzt erst äh frisch eingeschaltet haben, äh nochmal ganz kurz ein Management Summery geben, worum es in deinem äh Talk ging.
In meinem Talk oder?
Also in deinem Beitrag für den Ausschuss, meine ich.
Genau die Fragestellung waren äh oder das der Grund für diese Einladung war so ungefähr, dass sie sagten, wir haben hier diesen Hartgliedback, wir haben den, wir haben irgendwie diesen Snowden, der sagt, die ganze IT Security ist eh im Eimer ähm und,
da wollte jetzt quasi die Politik wissen, was äh sie tun können, ja?
Und ich habe mich hauptsächlich dann dazu geäußert, wie man die politischen Anreize korrekt so setzt, dass ähm,
Die IT-Sicherheit, die sich daraus ergibt, für die IT-Sicherheitskonzepte, ähm welche sind, die.
Ähm besseren Schutzversprechen. Und eingangs habe ich das verglichen mit den Städten im Mittelalter,
ja? Weil wir Mittelalter fingen die Menschen auf einmal an, haben Städte gebaut, hm? Und haben die Häuser in diesen Städten so gebaut, wie sie's kannten, nämlich mit ihren Dächern.
Und ähm das Problem, was sich daraus ergab, war, wenn jetzt eines dieser Häuser äh abbrannte,
dann stand das Reetdach in Flammen und griff auf die anderen Reddächer über, das heißt, ein kleines Problem in einem Haus führte zu einem Feuer in der gesamten Stadt.
Ähm und da habe ich den Vergleich zu IT-Security gezogen, dass man also die Dinge, die Architekturen und auch die äh Sicherheitssysteme so bauen muss, dass einzelne ähm einzelne Sicherheitslücken
immer angenommen werden und äh sich gegenseitig die Systeme gegenseitig so gesichert sind, dass keine
Stadtbrände mehr entstehen, ja? Und das ist ja auch eine Entwicklung, die die Menschheit dann im Mittelalter gemacht hat, haben gesagt, okay, wir ähm,
bauen die Dächer aus anderen Materialien, wir verwenden keine Redächer mehr in Städten,
Trotzdem brennen aber natürlich noch einzelne Häuser ab. Und ich denke, das ist der äh der entscheidende Punkt, den äh viele Menschen, die jetzt so zu Fragen der IT-Sicherheit und Verschlüsselung ähm.
Sich äußern, nicht verstehen
ist das jetzt ja aber wenn ich meine E-Mail verschlüsse, dann kann ja immer noch einer mit dem Trojaner
machen ist richtig
der Unterschied ist, deine E-Mails, die abgehört werden auf dem Mailserver, sind die von Millionen oder hunderttausenden von Nutzern und deine einzelne E-Mail, die abgehört wird mit, mit Hilfe eines Trojaners, erfordert einen sehr viel größeren, ähm, technischen Aufwand.
Und ähm das ist das, was was viele Menschen auch nach einem Jahr äh noch nicht verstanden haben, dass es eben Unterschied gibt aus zwischen dem individuellen Angriff auf mich, für den jemand äh einen größeren Aufwand betreiben muss. Und dieser Massenüberwachung,
den Punkt habe ich da glaube ich ganz äh sinnvoll mal vertreten.
Und das äh halte dann sogar bei der CDU nach.
Ja, erstaunlich war, äh ich war sehr äh begeistert mit dem äh Thomas Homberg habe ich mich schon vor Jahren äh zu Themen der Netzneutalität äh Netzneutralität ähm leidenschaftlich gestritten, ja.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich mich allzu positiv über ihn geäußert habe, als er das äh Zehn-Netz mitgegründet hat.
Ähm aber äh vielleicht entsteht ja eine neue.
Also der Beginn einer wunderbaren Freundschaft.
Soweit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen, aber ich betone ja immer, mir ist völlig egal, wer am Ende das Richtige macht.
Ja, okay, ne? Gut, dann bist du ja jetzt schon Teil des Establishments, ist doch auch ganz.
Das will ich ja sowieso schon seit Folge hundert.
Ja, das ähm merkt man auch an deinem beständigen Vordringen in äh neue Netzwelten, die noch nie.
Ja
Ähm das ist so, der Leona Dobby hat ein sehr interessanten Artikel beziehungsweise eine Studie quasi, wenn wenn man irgendwie noch an der Uni ist, ähm,
dann heißt ja alles immer Studie, ne? Man kann ja nicht einfach mal irgendwas machen, muss da eine Studie sein. Ähm,
hat da hat einen Artikel darüber geschrieben, dass äh die Zivilgesellschaft ähm also die Aktivisten,
irgendwie auf diesem Twitter rumhängen, während äh die meisten Menschen eben
da nicht sind, die sind bei Facebook, das heißt bei Twitter finden zwar angerichtete Debatten statt, die wird ja auch jeden jeden Monat wird einer mehr verrückt bei diesem Ding und äh,
aber die die große Masse der Menschen sitzt halt draußen bei bei Facebook und da kann man sich natürlich irgendwie drüber erheben und sagen, ja das sind alles die äh die doofen Facebook Klicker. Die haben alle keine Ahnung von Computern und Politik,
oder man kann eben äh sich bemühen äh diese Menschen auch zu erreichen, ja? Und damit seine.
Die Menschen da abholen, wo sie stehen.
Ja, genau, ne, am.
Am Katzenbild die Menschen abholen. Wobei ich nicht weiß, was man da bei Facebook macht. Und ich habe äh ja dann äh mir das zu Herzen genommen und habe gedacht, okay, da müssen wir mit dem Logbuch Netzpolitik auch zu zu Facebook.
Aber das geht gar nicht. Ich habe mich da ein, ich habe da versucht, was zu machen. Äh ich.
Es ist so furchtbar.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Also es ist wirklich Irrsinn, ja.
Das ist wirklich für Menschen, die einfach eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung ans Internet haben. Es ist da einfach wirklich schwierig. Ich kenne dieses Gefühl, ich habe das auch schon so ein paar Mal gemacht. Ich dachte mir auch so, was in der Welt ist, das jetzt so, was da ist.
Vor allem der funktioniert ja gar nicht. Ich habe oder ich.
Das geht, es geht einfach überhaupt nicht so, wie man das sich so denken würde.
Überhaupt nicht. Ich komme da rein ähm klicke das da irgendwie an und denke so, ja, okay, wer ist ja wohl jetzt mal schnell irgendwie so eine Facebook-Seite gebastelt kriegen,
dafür sorgen können, dass der RSS-Fit von Logbuch Netzpolitik mal schnell da reingepasst wird, so, ne? Kann ja nicht so schwer sein, das hätte eigentlich nur zwei Zeilen PAP und Facebook ist ja per P. Werden sie ja wohl mal irgendwann hingekriegt haben, ne.
Pustekuchen. Und ich habe überhaupt, ich weiß nicht, was ich da jetzt angerichtet habe. Es gibt jetzt eine Facebook-Seite, da stehen irgendwie zwei Sachen drin. Ich habe irgendwas versucht mit, dass der Fieter reingedönert wird.
Ja. Wir schauen uns das am besten nochmal an. Ich äh.
Mittag. Ja, ja, man man fühlt sich da unglaublich hilflos und vielleicht ist das auch mal ganz schön, so ein Gefühl bei uns zu erzeugen, weil sonst geht's wahrscheinlich den anderen Leuten auch so, bei äh unseren Netzen.
Ähm ja, mal gucken. Das Problem ist, man muss sich äh.
Dieses reine Rheinkippen von Nachrichten in unseren anderen Kanal, das nicht unbedingt jetzt so bei Filmen, also wenn man da sich wirklich engagieren will, dann muss man sich da halt auch engagieren. Das heißt, man muss da auch irgendwie
ähm Wege finden, wie man diese Interaktion da folgt und daran scheitert es ja schon mal bei Facebook ganz erheblich,
weil man einfach nicht die Werkzeuge dort vorfindet, die man einfach erwartet.
Die keine Kommentarfunktion?
Das Ding ist,
doch selbstverständlich haben sie das so und äh alles Mögliche läuft halt alles irgendwie nur durch diese Facebook-Apps uns läuft halt im Wesentlichen alles über diese Webseite. Ja und äh durch ihre Apps, aber so dieses äh,
da nicht ein besseres Programm für. Äh ja, das ist das schon mal schwierig.
Also wir können das ja mal so machen, jemand der also wir suchen einen Facebook-Experten. Ähm der kann sich bei.
Brauchen Beratung.
Genau, wir brauchen Social Media Berat.
Wir brauchen Social Media Berater, der uns erklärt, wie wir äh äh Logbuch Netzpolitik sinnvoll in Facebook einbinden, sodass wir keinen Ärger damit haben. Keine Arbeit, ich will mich damit nicht auseinandersetzen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Es sollen einfach die Folgen da äh erscheinen, sodass.
Das ist nicht das Problem, dass da irgendwas entscheiden zu lassen. Die Frage ist halt eher, wie soll man,
Also man muss einfach mal herausfinden, was wirklich ein sinnvoller Weg wäre, dort auch in Interaktion zu treten, weil du kannst ja jetzt nicht sagen, du willst dort Reaktionen erzeugen und dann gehst du auf diese Reaktion.
Ja, du willst.
Ich will, was ich möchte, Tim ist.
Nur Werbung machen. Hauptsache die Zahlen stimmen.
Weißt du, was ich will? Ich will Likes. So viel habe ich verstanden.
Keine Likes.
Man braucht Likes.
Also es war wirklich äh interessant. Ich weiß nicht, seit wie vielen Jahren ich seit vierundzwanzig Jahren setze sie mit Computern auseinander. Äh seit zwanzig Jahren oder was äh programmiere ich wild rum,
keine Ahnung, ich habe davor gestanden, dachte so, wat? Mama, was muss ich denn hier drücken?
Ja, ich kenne dieses Gefühl, ich habe das auch äh so alle gefühlte aller ein, zwei Jahre immer mit Facebook immer wieder gehabt, wo ich mein dickes, ah, jetzt guckst du dir das nochmal an und so, jetzt kann das bestimmt nicht sein und dann ist es immer so.
Ja, die Leute kommen damit klar, die kriegen das irgendwie hin. Keine Ahnung. Mir ist das zu kompliziert. Ich bin ja eh.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das soll.
Das ist ja die These, dass dieses Internet, dass äh dass Internet das überholt uns gerade rechts, weißt du? Wir sind bald, das wird nicht mehr lange dauern, dann sind wir die beiden Muppet-Opas, weißt du? Wir erzählen die ganze Zeit hier einen von von.
Wenn wir es nicht schon sind.
Wir sind, wir zählen hier die ganze Zeit ein von wie die gute Welt und was das Internet uns für blühende Landschaften verspricht. Und währenddessen, ne, ähm wächst dieses Facebook, der Snowden überwacht uns alle, ja? Und äh na ja.
Wir können nur noch zynisch aufm Balkon sitzen und uns über unsere eigenen Witze lachen.
Dann wollte ich noch ganz kurz was anderes bewerben,
ähm die haben Werbung verdient und zwar das Projekt äh Krautreporter, die ja eigentlich so eine Crowdfunding-Plattform waren für ähm.
Für journalistische Projekte. Auch äh unter anderem Podcast, die sich dadurch finanziert haben und so, sagt, wir haben.
Ein Krautreporter-Projekt, also im Prinzip Kickstarter für,
Für Podcaster, Blogger und Journalisten. Und die haben jetzt gesagt, sie machen quasi aus der sie machen noch das Magazin der Plattform selber. Die haben also sind also jetzt hingegangen und haben gesagt, sie wollen jetzt einen.
Wirklichen das Krautreporter Magazin machen. Und
wollen dieser ganzen Debatte, ich meine, seit zehn Jahren nörgeln die Online-Journalisten irgendwie rum. Ja, äh, Werbung ist aber auch, Mist, dann, dann müssen wir Klickstrecken machen, damit wir finanziert werden. Und
wollen aber auch irgendwie keinen Flat haben, weil das irgendwie keinen konstanten gibt und weiß ich nicht, seit zehn Jahren heulen die rum und die
die Krautreporter-Leute sind jetzt einfach hingegangen, haben gesagt, okay, hier machen wir das. Wir wollen,
Fünfzehntausend Abonnenten haben, die jeder im Monat einen Fünfer geben und damit betreiben wir ein investigatives Recherchemagazin äh ohne Werbung.
Und haben da einige Personen mit dabei, die ähm denen ich dazutraue, andere, denen ich nicht zutraue und noch andere, die ich überhaupt nicht kenne.
Ähm aber allein den Versuch, so etwas mal zu machen, kann man, glaube ich, nicht guten Gewissens scheitern lassen,
Und ähm mit einem Jahresabo-Nummer von sechzig Euro ist das, glaube ich, eine halbwegs äh günstige
äh Möglichkeit da mal äh neue Wege zu auszuloten. Und ähm deshalb,
bin ich dabei, beziehungsweise noch nicht. Ähm ich hab's nämlich noch nicht gemacht, aber ich will es, ich will dabei sein und äh möchte meinen Teil dazu beitragen, dass man dieses Projekt einfach mal auf die dass man das mal versucht, ja?
Kann ja auch schief gehen. Ist in Ordnung. Dann haben wir alle äh sechzig Euro äh in Wind geschossen und dann stirbt es in einem Jahr den Tod von AppDotnett,
wird alles Open Source. Aber ähm.
Ja, sicher.
Ne? Aber wir könnten mal ähm also ich ich halte das für ein Experiment, das überfällig ist und bin ein bisschen,
schockiert, dass das noch ein noch nicht längst sein äh Finanzierungsziel erreicht hat. Und äh deshalb möchte ich da jetzt hier an der Stelle auch nochmal dafür werben.
Ja, vielleicht ist es auch noch haben sie noch nicht so richtig klar gemacht, was eigentlich das Endprodukt wirklich äh
sein wird so, aber sie reden von Magazinen und sagen irgendwie so ja, man müsste sich schon vorstellen, was das ist so. Meine erste Frage war da, ja, was heißt das? Ist das jetzt irgendwie Bild oder Ton oder Text?
Offensichtlich ging man irgendwie total davon aus, dass jeder versteht, dass es sich dabei um ein Textmagazin,
handelt, wo dann, wie es so zwischendurch dann auch in den Reaktionen hieß, so,
auch mal Video dabei sein kann oder so, also das finde ich noch etwas unscharf. Also ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, auf was sie eigentlich hinaus wollen, ob da jetzt einfach nur weitere Textwüste äh entsteht,
oder ob das, sagen wir mal, auch als Magazin in irgendeiner Form sich anders aufstellt,
Darreichung der der Medienform,
Fand ich so ein so eine kleine verpasste Chance am Anfang. Äh ansonsten ja, ich habe nichts dagegen, dass das äh entsteht. Und bin gespannt, was äh wie sich das da so ähm.
Findet. Wie viele Leute sind das, ist äh ziemlich große Zahl von zwanzig, dreißig ähm,
Journalisten, die man halt auch so ein wenig kennt, wenn man im Internet unterwegs ist. Die meisten zumindest, alle haben mir jetzt nicht äh was gesagt, aber viele bekannte Namen waren dabei.
Gut, darauf haben wir hingewiesen. Dann können wir jetzt mal äh dann können wir jetzt mal zu unseren eigentlichen äh Themen kommen und da äh ist vor allem wieder mal eine Menge los in unserem Heimatland in Deutschland.
Im Heimatland stellte sich gestern dann heraus, wurde dann
aus gut unterrichteten Kreisen wurde bekannt, dass oh Schreck
Der Generalbundesanwalt Range wohl doch nicht ermitteln wird.
Ja? Wir werden in äh wir haben heute den achtundzwanzigsten Mai in genau einer, ja etwas in acht Tagen oder was, jährt sich dann, glaube ich, äh der der Einbruch des Slogan, ja?
Das heißt, ein Jahr.
Sagen, wo er wird nicht ermitteln im äh Hinblick auf die gesamte NSA Überwachung. Weil der hat das jetzt aus.
Netzpolitik äh berichtete. Nicht nur über den Generalbundesanwalt, sondern auch bei all die anderen Themen. Und man kann ja nun wirklich nicht sagen, äh Linus, dass da im letzten Jahr irgendetwas signifikantes veröffentlicht worden ist, oder?
Nein, nein,
aber das das Interessante ist seine die Begründung die jetzt da also er sagt es stünden ja weder Zeugen noch Dokumente zur Verfügung.
Ähm und dann wird gesagt.
Wenn man jetzt ein, also wenn jetzt der
wenn jetzt der Generalbundesanwalt nämlich einen Rechtshilfeersuchen an die US-Behörden stellt und ihn sie um Hilfe bei der Aufklärung bitte, dann geht er davon aus, dass diese Rechtshilfegesuche äh unbeantwortet bleiben würden
ja? Und wenn er bei den deutschen Geheimdiensten anfragt, dann und den deutschen Regierungsstellen, dann sagen die, sie haben nur Zeitungswissen.
Und der Spiegel betreibe Quellenschutz und verweigere die Herausgabe von den Dokumenten.
Dokumenten oder von den Quellen?
Na ja, die Quelle ist ja ist ja bekannter als die Dokumente, die der Spiegel hat, ja? Also beispielsweise es ging da konkret um die äh Handysache, da hätte wohl
so gerüchtet ist, ist eine Anfrage geben beim Spiegel, doch mal da die äh die komplette Datenbasis um äh Dokumentenbasis zu bekommen. Und der Spiegel hat wohl daraufhin gesagt, ja ähm nee.
Das sind unsere, die geben wir euch nicht. Ne? Also ähm.
Das Gericht, also ein Gericht ermittelt also nicht in einem Mordfall, weil es sein könnte, dass der Mörder sich nicht befragen lassen möchte.
So ungefähr der Staatsanwalt, ne?
Das Spannende ist eine schöne Meldung. Die äh Andre dann äh letzte Woche äh gestern auch äh heraus äh gab. Bei Netzpolitik org, nämlich,
Äh das erklärt dann wiederum einiges. Äh deutsche Beamte dürfen die Snowden-Enthüllungen nämlich gar nicht lesen. Ja und zwar,
äh wir wissen ja schon, dass äh US-Regierungsbeamte, die äh die noch nicht einmal die Medienberichte über die Snowden Sachen zitieren dürfen.
Und dann gab es dieses äh Rechtsgutachten, dass die Bundesregierung beauftragt hatte, wo es unter anderem auch um die ähm
rechtlichen Konsequenzen ginge, wenn jetzt der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss den Snowden zu sich äh einladen würde. In dem gleichen ähm Gutachten,
drohte man ja auch schon den Bundestagsabgeordneten mit Strafverfolgung, wenn sie sich damit näher auseinandersetzen?
Und jetzt hat andere dann an die Pressestelle des Innenministeriums die Frage gestellt, dürfen Mitarbeiter deutscher Behörden geheime Dokumente, die von Medien veröffentlicht wurden,
lesen und verarbeiten
Fragezeichen. Hat denn eine Antwort bekommen und die lautete, auch in Deutschland gilt der Grundsatz, dass das Unrechtmäßige öffentlich machen eingestufter Informationen, die Einstufung selbst nicht automatisch aufhebt.
Danach dürfen Bedienstete, Verschlusssachen nur dann lesen und verarbeiten, wenn sie entsprechend sicherheitsgeprüft zum Zugang zu Verschlusssachen ermächtigt sind und das Prinzip
Kenntnis nur, wenn nötig erfüllt ist.
Überhaupt nichts mehr zu ein. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Also die Bundesrepublik Deutschland darf sich sozusagen über die Spionage,
des eigenen Staates nicht informieren, weil sie ja mit dem spionierenden Staat ein Abkommen hat, darüber, dass man,
gegenseitigen Verschlusssachen nicht liest, woran sich aber die USA offensichtlich nicht hält, aber Deutschland schon,
Wow. Das also da muss man überhaupt erstmal drauf kommen, irgendwie auf sowas.
Kannste dir nicht.
Das ist doch wirklich super.
Ja und äh.
Das fand ich dann noch viel noch viel noch viel spannender jetzt, wir das der NSA Untersuchungsausschuss da am rumlavieren ist mit mit Snowden.
Ähm ist ja jetzt äh hinlänglich bekannt. Letzte Woche kamen sie dann auf die Idee und haben gesagt, na wenn wir den Snowden,
können wir zwar nicht hierhin einladen, aber,
Äh wir wollen ja irgendwie aus der Ferne befragen, müssen wir mal gucken, wie das geht. Da bleiben sie ja irgendwie so bleiben ja zumindest Teile der Ausschussmitglieder dran. Der äh Vorsitzende des Ausschuss, der Sensberg ja eher nicht. Ähm,
Das war übrigens auch sehr geil, dass äh das muss ich auch noch kurz wörtlich zitieren. Der ähm Vorsitzende des NSA Untersuchungsausschusses ähm.
Burg heißt ja nicht Sensberg, tschuldigung. Ähm.
Der sagte dann, ähm also snowden hatte ja gesagt, so wenn er äh in dem Untersuchungsausschuss aussagen wird, dann äh,
werden da wertvolle Hinweise bei rauskommen. Und sagt, er sei persönlich mit der Kommunikation aus Deutschland befasst gewesen. Ja, also.
Sagt also hier Jungs, ich kann euch wirklich was Spannendes erzählen,
Er habe selbst Analyseoperationen geleitet und dabei Systeme benutzt, die Kommunikation von Deutschen im großen Maßstab abfingen.
Und betont die verfassungsgemäßen Rechte jedes Bürgers in Deutschland wurden verletzt. Und dann sagt der Patrick Sendsburg, na ja, also
Ich bezweifle ja, dass der Snowden wesentliche neue Details entfüllen kann. Ähm.
Er sei nach den vorliegenden Erkenntnissen nie speziell mit der massenhaften Aussperrung deutscher Bürger in Deutschland befasst gewesen. Und wenn Snowden nicht bald mal Beweise in Form von Originaldokumenten vorliegt, verliert er jede Glaubwürdigkeit für den Untersuchungsausschuss,
Sagt der Vorsitzende Snowden hat bis zum heutigen Tage nichts geliefert, sagt Patrick, jetzt weißt du warum.
Es da diesen kleinen Wechsel gab, ne, an der Spitze des Untersuchungsausschusses, weil eben der vorherige Kandidat dort offensichtlich nicht bereit war, sich dermaßen äh äh lächerlich zu machen in der Öffentlichkeit. Spannender äh äh Punkt übrigens, ich war am Wochenende bei der Lesung von Glen Green World
dazu später noch mal kurz ein bisschen was, weil der hat dann interessant oder er hat da einen wichtigen, er hat das wieder so schön auf einen Punkt gebracht. Snowden.
Sitzt jetzt da in Russland, ja, ist von der von der mächtigsten Regierung der Welt mit dem größten Geheimdienstapparat der Welt und den mannigfasten Tötungsmöglichkeiten der Welt gesucht,
Die wollen den haben, die wollen den lebenslang hinter Gitter bringen, der hat sein komplettes, alles, was der hatte, hat er geopfert für diese Veröffentlichung, ja?
Und äh bangt jetzt da im Prinzip um die Zukunft seines Lebens, ja? Und die deutsche Regierung sagt, ey, ähm.
Wir wollen mehr.
Der Reiter für die exakt gar nichts zu geben. Gar nichts. Wir wir bieten dir noch nicht mal Schutz. Wir wollen einfach nur mehr. Bitte lieber snoten, reite dich noch mehr in die Tinte,
Für nichts,
für uns, wir sind nicht bereit, die auch nur ansatzweise Asyl oder sonst oder auch nur den kleinsten, leisesten Furz zu geben. Übrigens, wenn du in unser Land kommst,
dann liefern wir dich sofort aus, keine Sorge. Also du hast von uns nichts zu erwarten, aber gib mal noch ein bisschen Dokumente, weil wenn du was hast, dann wollen wir das sehen. Und dann fängt auch noch dieser Sensburg an, irgendwie,
zu behaupten, also ich meine, das ist ja ein Witz, dass irgendwie dieser irgendwie jemanden in Misskredit bringen könnte, ne. Es ist höchstens dadurch,
dass man sich auf den einlässt, aber ähm das ist doch wirklich, also das kannst du doch nicht mehr, also was stellen die sich denn vor.
Es ist wirklich.
Ich gehe ich denke, dass es alles ähm.
Also so blöd können die gar nicht sein, das gehört alles zu ihrem Spin, ja. Das ist jetzt so Teil dieser äh Schadensbegrenzung ist. Aber ich äh schweife ab, denn ähm,
Sie haben sich ja noch was Schöneres ausgesucht in dem in dem ausgedacht in ihrem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss und haben gesagt,
Ja ähm wir laden den Zuckerberg ein.
Der weiß ja offensichtlich alles.
Und zwar und zwar nicht nur den. Wir laden den Mark Zuckerberg ein, den Eric Schmidt, den Tim Cook äh und den Dick Costollo, also die Chefs von Facebook, Google, Apple und Twitter.
Und ehemalige Chefs des US-Geheimdienstes NSA, zum Beispiel Kieve Alexander und Michael Hayden, die laden wir alle bei uns in den Untersuchungsausschuss ein, aber nicht Edward Snowden.
Und dann meinen die also ernsthaft.
Können sich einen leeren Stuhl in einem deutschen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss nicht leisten. Und jetzt stellt man sich das mal so vor. Diese Firmen ja.
Facebook, Google und so, die sitzen ähm.
Grade in, also es ist bekannt, dass sie National Security Letters bekommen haben, dass sie äh Gag-Orders unterliegen, also dieser, diesen wahrscheinlich nicht äh verfassungsgemäßen Schweigeverpflichtungen, ja,
Und die versuchen sich da gerade gerichtlich gegen zu wehren, aber die sind momentan in dem Stand, dass sie äh gegen irgendwie einen,
mit drakonischen, fürchterlichen Strafen rechnen müssen, wenn sie sich äußern, ja?
Und jetzt stellst du dir vor, dass Mark Zuckerberg, ja, der setzt sich jetzt in seinen Privat-Chat fliegt rüber, setzt sich in diesen gammeligen Ausschusssaal, wahrscheinlich an das Mikrofon, wo ich vorher saß, wo noch der NSA-Aufkleber dran ist
und dann packt der mal so richtig aus, ne
dann packt der mal so richtig aus. Dann lässt der mal richtig einen vom Leder, ja und dann geht der ins Exil und dieses Facebook wird geschlossen, ne. Also ich weiß nicht, was sie sich was sie sich vorstellen. Natürlich kommt der nicht,
wenn der kommt, dann sitzt er da und sagt, guten Tag äh nennt einmal seinen Namen fürs Protokoll und reist dann wieder ab mit ein paar guten Willensbekundungen. Aber als wenn die jetzt irgendwie zur Aufklärung ähm äh zur Aufklärung beitragen würden, also du fragst dich wirklich,
was das soll und ich habe natürlich eine Theorie, nämlich und das sieht man ja jetzt langsam auch mit dem mit dem Google. Andre hat das ja in den letzten äh Woche schon äh auch besprochen. Ein weiterer Aspekt, der deutschen,
wirtschaftlichen Ausnutzung dieser Affäre ist natürlich auch diese Firmen nach und nach in Misskredit bringen zu wollen, ja? Da geht's jetzt irgendwie zerschlagt Google und äh was da jetzt alles für ähm,
für Forderungen auf dieser Welle mitreiten.
Das Google Problem. Hm.
Das Google-Problem, was ja auch eins ist, ja, ich find's nur interessant, dass man äh also hier werden halt zwei Dinge vermischt, ne. Ich meine jetzt also es ist ein völlig.
Weg vom Staat hin hin auf die Firmen, ne. Kleine Korrektur noch. Äh Schmidt ist natürlich nicht der Chef von äh Google,
sondern nur äh Aufsichtsrat äh Chef nicht, selbst das nichtsdestotrotz äh.
Man jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass das jetzt schon bei allen CDU-Abgeordneten angekommen ist, diese Information und äh spielt auch letztlich keine Rolle. Es wird natürlich niemand von denen,
auftauchen, Tim Cook wird sich ein Teufel scheren und alle anderen auch und das ist auch absolut nachzuvollziehen und dieser ganze Ausschuss muss ich sagen, das ist auch wirklich so mit die lächerlichste,
die ich wirklich bisher je gesehen habe im Deutschen Bundestag. Normalerweise sind ja diese Ausschüsse zumindest so, dass sie den den Anschein, zumindest den Anschein geben, äh das jeweilige Thema auch äh in etwa in Angriff zu nehmen. Aber was das hier wirklich
für einen einen Tanz um die heiße Kartoffel ist, das äh hätte ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht für möglich gehalten.
Aber ich bin mal, ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Also wenn dann
wenn dann hier der Zuckerberg oder so absagt, dann kannst du aber sicher sein, dass das äh Bildzeile äh Bild äh Zeile Nummer eins ist. Und während dieser gleiche äh NSA Untersuchungsausschuss eben eine Befragung von Snorden
im Prinzip verhindert und ablehnt und den Mann irgendwie ein Misskredit
bringt, werden sie eine riesen Theater machen, dass der, der, der, der, der böse Datenarmee äh nicht ähm äh zu dieser Ausschusssitzung,
ja? Und das also das ist also absolut äh lächerlich. Aber der Tanz um die heiße Kartoffel ist bei ihrer ersten öffentlichen äh Tagung ja auch sehr schön äh,
sehr schön äh misslungen,
da waren ja dann ähm mehrere äh äh dekorierte Juristen, unter anderem der Hans-Jürgen Papier, der ehemalige Präsident des Bundesverfassungsgerichts und da waren, die waren da also als Sachverständiger in diesem Ausschuss.
Und so ungefähr das Erste, was denen erstmal in ihrem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss äh von den Sachverständigen erklärt wird, ist ähm der Bundesnachrichtendienst handelt in Teilen grundgesetzwidrig,
und zwar äh führt er ja eine anlasslose, flächendeckende Speicherung von Daten durch, kooperiert außerdem noch mit der NSA und das mit dem deutschen Grundgesetz nicht vereinbar,
ähm auch, dass da irgendwelche Geheimdienste abkommen, ist absolut verfassungswidrig. Erst recht, wer diese äh wer diese Abkommen geheim sind.
Die Bundesregierung hat dem dann noch entgegengehalten. Ja, aber die Überwachung ist ja gesetzlich festgelegt. Äh und dann wurde natürlich gesagt, ja gut,
Gesetz, äh das hat scheint ja die Bundesregierung eh nicht zu verstehen, dass auch Gesetze sich an die Verfassung halten müssen, ne. Ans Grundgesetz halten müssen. Ähm,
Das heißt, ähm das Gesetz beschreibt eine Aufgabe, aber ermächtigt eben nicht zu dieser Vollüberwachung und es kann nicht angehen,
dass solche wichtigen Grundrechte ins Leere laufen, sagt dann der erstmal der,
Papier in dem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss. Und da sieht man im Prinzip jetzt endlich mal das, was ich
mir schon seit einiger Zeit erhofft habe und jetzt wo das sich ein Jahr jährt, ein Jahr jährt dieses Nordensache, erinnere ich mich natürlich auch an unsere erste Reaktion darauf
wo wir irgendwie, sage ich mal, die, das historische Ausmaß dieser Enthüllung noch ein bisschen äh
niedriger eingeschätzt haben und sagten, ja äh irgend so ein Ami hat da ein paar Sachen von der NSA gelied, stellt sich raus, das ist ein Geheimdienst, als wenn das irgendein Geheimdienst der Welt anders machen würde.
Ähm,
Und das ist natürlich der Punkt, den man äh sich immer auch wieder in Erinnerung rufen muss. Es macht kein Geheimnis der Welt anders und es ist nicht nur eine NSA-Affäre, sondern es ist eine weltweite Massenüberwachungsaffäre.
Und ich finde das sehr schön, dass in diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt als allererstes mal die Scheinwerfer relativ hell auf den Bundesnachrichten,
Dienst leuchten. Das finde ich eine schöne Entwicklung.
Trotzdem muss man schon feststellen, dass dieser Spin an sich immer noch relativ gut greift. Ja, also es ist schon ähm,
schläfrige Stumpfheit äh der Massen äh die Einstein schon beobachtet hat, die ist äh nach wie vor vorhanden.
Ähm,
Heute gibt's dann noch ein Verfahren vor dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht. Das fängt um zwölf Uhr an, also erst in vielen Stunden, da sind wir also jetzt noch weit voraus, wo die Rechtmäßigkeit der Filterung von E-Mails, also die strategische Fernmeldeüberwachung
auf dem Prüfstand steht, ja? Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig.
Ähm und da klagt also ein Anwalt gegen die strategische Fernmeldeaufklärung. Das ist das, wo es dreißigtausend Suchbegriffe gibt, die ähm,
über unsere E-Mails äh angewendet werden, um da entsprechend herauszufiltern. Äh und den Kampf gegen den Terror äh voranzutreiben.
So die äh Legende und da wird äh heute schon das Ergebnis der Verhandlung erwartet, weil das Bundesverwaltungsgericht wohl schon ausführliche Fragen gestellt hat, die äh in eine gewisse Richtung,
vermuten lassen. Also bin mal gespannt, was da dann heute vor dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht noch passieren wird.
Ja, aber man sieht, Deutschland setzt sich nach wie vor aktiv mit diesem Thema auseinander. Wir auch.
Ja, wir werden sehen, wie's weitergeht. Es wird bestimmt spannend werden.
Ja und unser Industrieminister ist äh auch ganz fleißig.
Ja, das ist so ein das ist echt ein Thema. Er hat jetzt angekündigt.
Sigmar Gabriel.
Dass man neue neue Kabinen noch nicht so ganz drauf haben.
Der hat ähm angekündigt, dass er ein Verbot ein Exportverbot von Späßsoftware vorantreiben möchte.
Und ähm das ist ein Thema, wo man.
Wo ich schon sehr viel drüber gesprochen habe, äh mit anderen Leuten, die sich da auch besser auskennen als ich und was auf Anhieb natürlich so total
cool klingt ne? Dass man sagt ach ja genau das verbieten wir und dann dann liefert Deutschland keine Überwachungssoftware mehr in Unrechtsregime, ja?
Und jetzt stellt man sich mal so vor, wie willst du denn ein solches Exportverbot? Wie willst du das definieren?
Ja? Ähm,
Was ja Siemens gemacht hat. Ich glaube, das war Siemens, ne? Ähm klar, Nokia hat äh die die Überwachungssparte von Nokia Siemens Networks hieß gehörte früher zu denen, wurde dann irgendwann umbenannt in Trophychor und in ein anderes Land verlegt.
Mhm. Welches denn?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr. Es ist, ich bin da leider äh meine Recherchen haben da vor einiger Zeit aufgehört. Ich habe da mal relativ viel zu gewusst und auch zu geschrieben. Kann mich da aber an dieser Stelle nicht dran erinnern. Ähm.
Nee, Trophy ist immer noch eine deutsche Firma. Nein, Hauptsitz in München, Niederlassung in Dubai, Islamabad und Kuala Lumpur.
Ja, du siehst, in welche Richtung das geht. So, jetzt diese diese Firma äh stellt also zum Beispiel Überwachungstechnik her und verkauft die in die gesamte Welt, äh gehörte früher zu Siemens,
und äh Siemens hat äh das zweitausendsieben.
Ähm dann erstmal in Nokia Siemens, Networks überführt und zweitausendneun äh sich von diesem Ding getrennt. Ja?
Ähm die Firma gibt's natürlich nach wie vor und jetzt hat die ihre Firmensitze in vier Ländern dieser Erde. Ähm.
Und jetzt natürlich die Frage, wie willst du jetzt verhindern, dass die das das die Produkte exportieren.
Aus Deutschland oder aus der EU hinaus. Ja, die haben in einem Tag eine Firma in irgendeinem anderen Land gegründet ähm und wer jetzt für wen was produziert, du kannst ja diesen Export überhaupt nicht ähm nicht kontrollieren.
Ja, da wird irgendwie eine Software erzeugt und irgendwelche Systeme geschmiedet vor Ort und das geschieht dann halt einfach, ja.
Am Ende verkauft's irgendeine andere Firma in ausm anderen Land und zahlt dann da auch noch die Steuern dafür, ja? Wenn sie überhaupt Steuern zahlen,
Das heißt, wir haben da auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, als es um das Exportverbot von Space Software aus dem Vereinigten Königreich ging.
Wo es insbesondere um die Produkte der Firma Gamma ging, aber Gamma International hat eben auch äh überall auf der Welt ähm Niederlassungen.
Oder Briefkastenfirmen. Das heißt,
Lieferung von Software zumindest ist sehr schwer und auch äh zu kontrollieren, ebenso die Lieferung von ähm von Hardware, ne.
Nicht nur die Lieferung, ich denke auch die die Klassifikation von äh Spielsoftware äh ist einfach auch sehr schwierig, ne. Zumal ja eben vieles von was potenziell
sagen wir mal in einer Methode äh verwendet werden kann, die uns jetzt auch selbst nicht so passt.
Teilweise eben sehr wohl auch legitime Network Management Eingriffe sein können, ja? Und es kann ja eigentlich auch äh zunächst einmal niemanden,
verboten werden, seine Netzwerke zu managen. Ja, was dieses Management letztlich bewirkt, äh ist halt eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Kommst du auch noch auf den wichtigen Punkt, größerer Teil der Telekom, was dessen, was für Telekommunikationsüberwachung genutzt wird, ist ja schon in den Geräten drin. Ja, also wenn du jetzt
ein
Telefonnetz, Mobiltelefonnetz oder eine Serverinfrastruktur baust, ja? Also ich mein wenn du einen E-Mail-Server hast, brauchst du keine
keine Überwachungsanlage mehr daneben zu stellen. Ja, der E-Mail-Server hat das ja bereits alles. Ähm das heißt, diese diese die Überwachungsfunktion ist teilweise überhaupt nicht von den Geräten ähm oder von den von den Applikationen
äh trennscharf abzugrenzen.
Von den Diensten an sich ist es schon fast gar nicht abzugrenzen.
Genau,
Also das ist eine ist eine spannende Sache und da gibt's dann äh einige Überlegungen auch, äh da könnten wir uns vielleicht mal den äh Experten von CCC mal dazu holen, wenn dieses Thema größer wird. Ähm,
wo das natürlich dann auch unter Umständen solche ähm Gesetze sehr unangenehme Folgen haben für.
IT äh Sicherheitsforscher. Kommen wir also in diesem Bereich des Hacker Paragrafen. Also es klingt nach einer ziemlich dämlichen Idee.
Deren Wirksamkeit sehr unwahrscheinlich äh als sehr unwahrscheinlich einzustufen ist. Ich denke, die soziale Ächtung äh derartiger ähm.
Derartiger Firmen und derartiger Geschäftspraxen ist der bessere Weg, aber zu dieser Echtung kann natürlich auch dieses Exportverbot beitragen und da da dazugehören. Das heißt, ähm.
Da kommt's dann wirklich darauf an, wie dann so ein solches Gesetz im Detail ähm ausformuliert sein wird.
Gut. Dann ähm.
Kommen wir endlich in die USA.
Kommen wir endlich, endlich in die USA, genau.
Ja, Glen Green World hat ein Buch veröffentlicht. Ähm heißt auf Englisch, wie es auf Deutsch heißt, weiß ich nicht
Ähm,
Und er hat jetzt auch grade eine kleine Deutschlandtournee hinter sich. Er hat's mir natürlich nicht nehmen lassen als äh Fanboy äh diese
dieses dieses Gespräch in in Berlin was er da mit dem Zeitmagazin oder mit der Zeit geführt hat mir dann auch live im deutschen Theater anzuschauen.
Ähm das Buch selber, ähm,
hat einige neue Hintergrundinformationen mit da drin, ähm aber jetzt keine großartigen neuen Enthüllungen und schildert so ein bisschen seine.
Ähm,
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen auch die Homestory dazu, ne, also wie er und Laurel, dann irgendwann nach China flogen und wie sie dann Snowden getroffen haben und mit wem sie dann so
gesprochen habe, was beim Guardian hinter den Kulissen äh abging und so. Ist ein ganz, ganz interessanter ähm ganz interessantes äh.
Büchlein, was man sich so durchlesen kann, indem er natürlich dann auch sehr schön,
ähm die politischen Erwägungen zu diesen Enthüllungen nochmal äh sauber vorträgt. Kann man, glaube ich, empfehlen.
Aber das ist jetzt nur die Lesung mitbekommen, du hast es noch nicht selbst gelesen.
Doch selbstverständlich, also es ich habe es äh selbst gelesen und das, was dort ähm,
Was dort stattfand, war keine Lesung, sondern ein ein Gespräch. Ja, also es ist jetzt, er setzt sich da nicht hin und liest aus dem Buch vor, sondern er führt ein, führt ein Gespräch mit,
mit diesem Moderator. Wobei das bei Glen Green World keinen Unterschied macht, denn der Mann spricht wie gedruckt, der hat kein einziges Mal eher gesagt, der hat kein einziges Mal nachgedacht und der,
trägt einen sehr klaren, präzisen Gedanken, auch über mehrere Ebenen vor
auch auf eine Frage aus dem Publikum, auf die er sich offensichtlich nicht vorbereitet hat. Es ist allein aus dem Grund schon eine Wonne, diesen Menschen zuzuhören. Ist wirklich,
ähm,
irre. Also ist einfach beeindruckend, wie klar und deutlich und äh der Mann spricht und alle Sachen immer sowas von einhundert Prozent auf den Punkt bringt.
Und das auch mit einem ähm politischen Eifer natürlich gepaart. Äh den ich äh sehr sympathisch finde. Also es ist wirklich ein,
ähm.
Beeindruckender Typ, das hat sich ja auch schon bei der der Keynote, die er aufm Kongress gehalten hat, auf dem dreißig C drei auch gezeigt, da war er im selben Maße souverän, wie du das jetzt gerade beschreibst.
Also es ist echt, das ist äh beeindruckend. Habe ich natürlich auch so ein bisschen äh Gänsehaut bekommen und so, ne, kurz äh kurz seine Hand absolut, absolut, absolut. Ähm.
Fanboy, Fanboy, Fanboy. Hm, hier ist die Greenies.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass er, äh, aber ich mein, worüber soll er noch stolpern? Also, ich meine, Sie haben ihn jetzt versucht, wegen seiner Homosexualität fertig zu machen. Das hat nicht geklappt und er chillt irgendwie in Brasilien mit seinen Hunden,
und seinem Freund und ähm.
Verweigert die Zusammenarbeit mit Regierung übrigens. Also er hat dann auch gesagt, ja, wenn die deutsche Regierung ihn fragen, fragt, äh ob er da in diesen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss geht, das äh betrachtet er nicht als seine Aufgabe, er ist Journalist.
Ähm,
Ja, also davon gibt's, glaube ich, auf eine auch eine Aufzeichnung. Das Buch äh empfehlen wir zum Kauf und ähm ansonsten sind wir sowieso völlig verblendete Fanboys und äh
Der Kritik an diesen Menschen momentan nicht fähig. Wer allerdings fähig war zur Kritik an ähm Glen Green World, war äh Julio
Julio Sanchez meldete sich aus dem äh Exil in der äh equadorianischen Botschaft, denn,
Glen Green World, er enthüllte ja, dass die USA,
einige Länder vollständig abhören und nannte das Land der Bahamas aber ein anderes Land nicht.
Und zwar unter Berufung darauf, dass er sagte, wenn äh wir das enthüllen, dann ist nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass darauf eine Welle der Gewalt,
folgt und äh die möchten wir verhindern und aus diesem Grunde, aus diesem Grunde äh,
Nennen wir diesen Namen nicht. Den Namen dieses Landes.
Und das hat ja bei dieser Lesung auch eher äh erklärt, denn seine äh seine Erwägung war auch eine, also neben der tatsächlichen, dem tatsächlichen Versuch, Gewalt zu verhindern, auch eine,
strategische, dass er nämlich sagte, sollte da tatsächlich auf eine unserer Enthüllungen,
eine Gewalttat folgen, bei der äh beispielsweise Gott bewahre ein Amerikaner, sich einen Fingernagel abreißt, ähm
Dann wird das natürlich katastrophale Folgen für seine und ihre
insbesondere die politische Mission von AdWord Snowden haben, weil er dadurch äh massiv in Misskredit geraten würde. Das heißt, aus ähm.
Auch aus Schutz vor der äh oder oder um die eigene Sache zu schützen,
hat er eben diese äh diese Entscheidung getroffen,
und ähm da hat er auch von Edward Snowden einen einen klaren Arbeitsauftrag erhalten, schon noch in Hongkong, ja, ist ihm also gesagt wurde so ähm pass auf, du kannst machen, was du möchtest, aber.
Und jenes sind die Gefahren, die die für unsere Mission hier bestehen und da müssen wir aufpassen, da müssen wir vorsichtig sein. Ähm,
Wiki Leaks in Form oder Julian Assange in Form des Twitter-Accounts von WikiLeaks hat dann lange
darüber und gesagt, ja hier keine radikale Transparenz, genau das gleiche wie äh wie der Guardian damals mit uns versucht hat und so weiter, finden wir alles nicht gut.
Ähm und setze dann Glenwold ein Ultimatum und sagte, wenn das in drei Tagen nicht genannt, hat dieses Land, dann wird Wiki Leaks es tun,
und tat es dann auch und äh was eh schon sich jeder denken konnte, das Land war äh Afghanistan.
Aber es war eine spannende ähm,
Eine spannende Debatte, ja, so eben auch so zu überlegen, okay, was was können wir nennen? Ähm was nicht. Da spielt natürlich dann auch wieder rein das Edward Snodenjahr sich nach wie vor als äh,
US-amerikanischer Patriot sieht und bezeichnet, ähm der äh natürlich keinen Schaden auf sein Land äh bringen möchte.
Dann eben diese strategischen Erwägungen, dann natürlich auch diesen Anspruch auf eine radikale äh Transparenz. Das ist schon eine,
wie ich finde spannende Auseinandersetzungen da gewesen.
Und äh der afghanische Präsident hat dann jetzt angekündigt, ja, das was die Amis uns hier hingestellt haben, das machen wir jetzt mal wieder aus. Diese äh Massenüberwachung und
da ist natürlich jetzt auch für die Amerikaner ein großer Hebel, an dem sie ziehen können und sagen können, dadurch, dass wir die Afghanen nicht mehr so gut kontrollieren können, entsteht uns ein
Nachteil im Kampf gegen den Terrorismus, weil da sind ja Terroristen im Land.
Da kommt man dann also, finde ich, erstmals so auch in diese Erwägung, wo solche Gedanken durchaus auch meine eine Rolle spielen.
Was für Gedanken eine Rolle spielen.
Na ja, der Gedanke, äh äh radikale Transparenz oder nicht, klärst du das auf, dass die Afghanistan abhören ähm
mit der Konsequenz, dass eine Menge Afghanen, also falls noch nicht alle Afghanen absolut pisst sind auf die USA, dann ist es der letzte jetzt auch,
und äh mit der weiteren Konsequenz, dass diese äh abhören, dieses Abhören und in unter Umständen in Zukunft
nicht mehr möglich ist und dass das ein strategischen Nachteil für die militärischen Operationen der USA bedeutet und theoretisch dazu führen könnte, äh dass äh ja
Menschenleben, US-amerikanische oder afghanische Menschen leben in Gefahr geraten. Ja, ist jetzt äh,
zumindest nicht von der Hand zu weisen, dass es da eine theoretische Möglichkeit gibt. Und diese wiederum,
kann äh dazu führen, dass es ein ähm das ist auch der, der, der Sache der Aufklärung als solcher schadet.
Ich meine es natürlich sehr schwierig für
Journalisten grundsätzlich, wie es schon für Staaten auch sehr schwierig ist, wird dich da auch eine Sicherheitseinschätzung zu machen, weil so eine Abschätzung wie äh kann eine Information zu Umstürzen oder ähm kriegerischen Einsätzen oder auch nur,
ähm äh vergleichbaren Verhältnissen führen in einem Land, das ist ja sagen wir mal so das typische Assessment, was von so einem Geheimdienst dann auch einer Regierung angetragen wird.
Also,
irgendwas fällt vor und dann äh geht die Kanzlerin zum Geheimdienst und sagt, ja, äh wie schätzt ihr denn, dass da ein, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie dieses und jedes Statement machen, was kann denn das für Folgen haben
finde ich das jetzt insofern als das eben auf diesem Level quasi Greenwald auch als Journalist ganz alleine agiert.
Mit seinem Wissen. Wahrscheinlich hat er mittlerweile auch schon zu viel Dokumente gelesen, dass er irgendwie auf dem selben Stand ist wie die NSA.
Ähm und das dann eben auch äh Teil seiner Umsetzung macht. Und das ist ja auch grundsätzlich zu beobachten bei Snowden, der ja auch sich immer noch sehr als.
Aufrechter US-Bürger versteht und ja auch gerne wieder äh zurückkehren würde. Es gab jetzt auch Meldungen, dass es da irgendwelche Verhandlungen laufen, keine Ahnung, was da dran ist und welche ähm ob's da irgendeine realistische,
Chance dafür gibt. Aber äh so grundsätzlich stehen sie ja immer auf diesem Standpunkt,
wir wollen hier aufklären über einen Missbrauch des Systems, uns geht's aber nicht jetzt irgendwie Amerika als solches an den Pranger zu stellen. Das wiederum ist ein Eindruck, den man halt, sagen wir mal, bei Assange.
Jetzt nicht so hat.
Äh spannend, dass du das noch ansprichst mit dem äh Snowden, tatsächlich sein deutscher Anwalt, der Herr Kalek äh ist in Gesprächen mit US-Regierungskreisen
über Umstände, die jetzt eine, sage ich mal, äh, Rückkehrsnotens in die Heimat äh ermöglichen würden. Klar, solche Gespräche führt man mal, da lotet man mal was aus. Ich halte das natürlich für absolut ähm
absolut unwahrscheinlich, dass sich da irgendwas in der Richtung ergeben könnte.
Allein aus Gründen der Abschreckung, ja? Also die USA müssen, sie können gar nicht anders diesen Menschen Edward Snowden,
mit allem bedrohen, was sie haben und unbedingt fürchterlich äh grausam zum Schweigen bringen, denn wenn sie es nicht tun,
stiften sie andere an, die sich dann denken, ach ja, Mensch, dem Snowden ist das auch durchgegangen, dann kann ich jetzt ja hier auch mal den machen, dass äh die fünf Jahre äh,
Sozialarbeit, die kriege ich schon hin, ja? Ähm und genau natürlich sieht man das auch am Beispiel äh Chelsea Manning, dass da einfach,
sich nichts anderes leisten können, als mit der großen Keule draufzuhauen, um äh Nachahmer abzuschrecken.
Ja, kann schon sein, dass das alles keine besondere Zukunft hat, also solche ähm Verhandlungen zu führen. Ähm man könnte es auch so sehen, dass das ähm sag mal, strategisch auch sehr klug ist von Snowden, so überhaupt mal vorzugehen
unabhängig von den Ergebnissen dieser Verhandlung, weil man sieht das ja auch gerade in den letzten Wochen und Monaten,
dass sich in den USA auch sagen wir mal so eine ich weiß nicht, ich will's nicht Opposition nennen, aber die Unterstützung in der, zumindest in einem bestimmten Teil der Öffentlichkeit, ja,
Snowden. Also ein Teil der Öffentlichkeit der USA selbst,
die ist sehr groß, also generell diese Methode ihn als den Bösewicht schlechthin an die Wand zu stellen, ein Verräter und was nicht alles,
Das mag bei unverbesserlichen äh Rednicks da auch äh problemlos funktionieren, ja?
Nur ähm ist es auch so, dass Snowden halt äh,
per Video bei der South by's House West Konferenz, ja, also so der äh.
Internetveranstaltungen, da als irgendwie groß auf den Beamer geworfen wurde und da eben auch umjubelt wurde. Also es gibt da einfach schon auch eine aufgeklärte und eben nicht,
marginalisierbare Gruppe. Ja, grade auch so diese Internetwirtschaft
Also wir reden jetzt nicht so von den üblichen Verdächtigen Hippies und, und, und, und, und, und linken Resistenzlern, die es natürlich auch den USA gibt, sondern schon auch so um ein wirtschaftlich relevanten Teil der Bevölkerung
die einfach
überhaupt nicht bereit sind, diese pauschale Sicht der Regierung einfach so zu kaufen und die auch grundsätzlich gegen die ganze Überwachung etwas hat. Und das ist natürlich auch eine
Opposition, hab ich doch gesagt, aber sagen wir mal ein, ein, ein, ein Teil an nicht unwichtiger Teil der Gesellschaft, mit dem sich auch eine Regierung,
auseinandersetzen muss. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie grade einfach jeden beliebigen Bullshit der Öffentlichkeit verkaufen können, selbst wenn Fox News da mitspielt
dann ähm ist da auf jeden Fall noch eine Menge Luft und äh der Kampf ist da auch noch lange nicht gewonnen für die Amerikaner.
Das ist richtig, aber sie haben eben trotzdem diesen Geheimdienstapparat, von dem sie sich sicherlich nicht trennen wollen und ähm der eben.
Äh sich nicht leisten kann, dass da dass da äh andere Regeln auf einmal herrschen, was die den Umgang mit Geheimhaltung geheim zu haltenden Informationen äh angeht. Also wir werden mal sehen, ähm,
was da jetzt so sicherlich ist nicht blöd, dass der äh mal mit den mit den Amis redet und wir werden halt
es bleibt ja sowieso spannend. Das finden wir ja auch schön an der ganzen Sache. Ähm aber ich würde mich jetzt so wundern, wenn äh Snowden irgendwie unbefleckt in die USA zurückreisen
kann und dann vielleicht weiter arbeitet bei Dell oder so, ja oder bei Buß bei Hamilton oder was.
Dann war noch schön äh ähm
Das sind eher nur so Rand äh Randwitze, ja, die so dann in den in den Medien kommen. Äh in den USA werden gerade ein paar chinesische Hacker äh angeklagt, die äh die angeblich Daten gestohlen hätten oder Industriespionage betrieben hätten.
Und dann äh war auch eines der schönsten, dass
auf dem Postweg manipuliert werden, also von der äh NSA abgefangen und dann ähm manipuliert und weitergesendet werden. Und dazu muss man wissen, Cisco-Geräte, das äh sind eben die großen
Router mit den riesigen Flugzeugturbinen Ventilatoren dran, aus denen große Teile des Internets gebaut werden.
Und dass die also äh,
manipuliert werden von der NSA und so dann in andere Länder ausgeliefert werden. Das ist natürlich schon so der die
das ist das, was man die ganze Zeit äh Huawei äh nachsagt, die als Konkurrent in den letzten zehn Jahren äh sich ganz gut äh gegenüber Cisco äh positioniert haben,
Aber das ist schon irgendwie das sind Meldungen, die sind ja dann äh inzwischen sowas von absurd, dass sie äh,
kaum noch wahrgenommen werden, weil man sie
in ihrer Absurdität schon für völlig normal hält. Der CEO von äh Sisco hat sich auf jeden Fall bei Obama beschwert. Und Cisco klagt nach wie vor über äh nennenswerte Umsatzeinbußen.
Erst recht, seit äh Beginn dieser Snowden-Affäre und da äh ist eventuell doch noch mal eine Möglichkeit, dass äh,
sich da vielleicht irgendwie nochmal was ändert.
Wenn's ums Geld geht, dann bewegt sich was.
Genau und das äh ist eine schöne Überleitung zu meinem Dank, der in dieser Sendung der lieben Sarah und dem äh Steffen äh gilt, die beide sicherlich auch wissen, wofür.
Und ähm damit habe ich alles gesagt, was ich sagen wollte. Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir aussieht. Du willst wahrscheinlich noch sagen, dass wir diesen Facebook-Rahm rausschneiden müssen und das schnell.
Ich find's okay, dass wir da jetzt mal in eine Diskussion gegangen sind und ich find's auch interessant zu sehen, dass du auch ausm Stand dieselben Schmerzen äh hattest, die ich auch hatte.
Müssen wir mal gucken, äh wie wir da weitermachen. Ich bin da äh etwas ähm gespalten.
Nächste Woche YouTube. Tim, ich muss Schluss machen.
Ja, wir sind durch mit dieser Woche. Wir äh haben gerade wirklich Schwierigkeiten, gute Termine zu finden, aber wir bleiben dran. Wir grüßen alle, bis bald, tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.